what's going on reject nation I'm Greg
Alva I am jonald M Humphrey we are going
to watch a trailer for a horror movie
here from Ireland which debuted SXSW
South by 2018 in the visions section
it's called don't leave home the story
of Greg and John's YouTube career today
yeah we go watch this came highly
recommended
October is coming around might as well
start checking out some horror and what
better than some indie horror am i right
people this comes out in like a little
bit actually September 14th in
video-on-demand theaters dude okay cool
all right well let's let's watch this
[Music]
you might hear some strange things whoa
what about the Commission is there a
particular piece I'm supposed to make
clearest rehabilitated righto in the
would-be of the house father both things
that that would make for a very
successful sale the other day when I
first saw the grotto and this valley and
I can explain it you did have a father
but request not to tell anyone about
your visit no one knows I'm here I'm
sorry to public opinion the island does
not overflowing with get out with
[Music]
capitalism set to depart today no we are
certainly not going to check on you
[Music]
you are here for a reason my dear it's
funny we usually check out like the big
trailers and stuff like that we really
do we take the time to check on these
indie ones but this looks good yes
really good a really atmospheric and
engrossing movie I mean like got that
line about the castle yeah few times in
this channel we grew up Catholic men in
Catholic school Catholic guilt is a
thing I very much identify with hundred
percent hundred ten and I always tell
people too that even though these days I
don't really consider myself Catholic I
am guilty I am always feeling guilty and
I am always feeling scared of demonic
horror because of my Catholic upbringing
that stuff always gets to my head so
watching this mixture of it in this film
I was thinking that like Irish people
Catholic a little bit of a get out vibe
you know - all the black people
I thought of get out and also like
hereditary if she actually left the
house and got some sculpting done yeah I
mean it has a rather simple cliche kind
of plot you know person goes to this
house remote job he said everyone's all
rich this time except for the stupid
Americans Americans are dumb in other
countries but I learned from movies it's
rank the DOS Americans yeah she doesn't
look dumb here know what I love about
this trailer it's like there's some
great cinematography easily and usually
for like indie horror that does plenty
for me because like hereditary earlier
an indie horror film and I was bringing
it up to how we usually check out the
bigger films for these trailers and
stuff but it's always nice to see like a
smaller budget film look this
professional yeah and look really assure
yes like this if this if someone told me
this is a Blum House movie yeah I would
be like yeah looks like one yeah you
never know I and II horror you never
know quite what you're getting into and
sometimes you're getting into something
very loath I kind of around the edges
but yeah this looks really a shirred and
really deliberate but also pretty
chilling I mean I liked it as a horror
trailer I can't exactly put a finger on
what the malevolence is because some of
it looks like it's definitely coming
from the priest and and this woman here
but some of it looks like there's that
moment where she sees herself in the
window and I love those kind of like
weird doppelganger things and they're
also some like demonic ghosts looking
stuff and with that appraisal of this
being kind of like get out with Catholic
guilt and I'm wondering how much it's
gonna be figurative how much is gonna be
literal and that's exciting to me yeah
is it gonna do more of a babadook kind
of thing without ruining the bobbity
more babadook kind of thing will it do
kind of that hereditary kind of style
also noticing that a lot of these horror
movies these days and this definitely
has it too
the horror visuals the way they work the
lens in the film it has very much a
throwback v to something of like a 70s
60s kind of horror style with long shots
of animals and stuff yeah the crash
zooms that yeah yeah the even the slope
Hannon's as well there's a lot of that
kind of visual flair here it's cool to
go back to that because that's what
really made horror more in the film
territory yeah especially lately and I
don't know I mean once I see one of
these trailers I'm like I just want to
hunker down and watch a bunch ad [ __ ]
yeah but yeah this looks like it's tone
its atmosphere has that kind of eerie
build up vibe that will just get under
your skin as the round keeps going you
know you got to love some good dreading
dread I have a feeling it'll be one of
those finales were I'm like what yeah
okay I need to talk to someone who
understands this interpretation that was
creepy and weird but I don't understand
it literal or figured everyone wanted to
call me an idiot for not knowing how
this ended yeah secretly no no
really this looks really cool I hope I
get diseases it's a nice palette the
acting looks good and you know a lot of
horror films these days tend to have a
plot like a setup that's very familiar
it's all about its execution looks
different and the execution here looks
like wonderfully dreadful the piping
yeah and like elegant and restrained in
a way which is you know nice - after
Halloween you know yeah a stick shift
gear and with the way it's being
directed to is on video on demand but
I'm like this looks like a theatre
experienced yeah I mean this is the kind
of theatre experience I'd like to see
these kind of visuals on the big screen
yeah yeah and soaked in the dread like
let that mounting tension wash over you
yeah kind of try and grab you from the
screen across the room yeah other than
feeling like the main setup is a little
bit cliche its execution looks unique
enough to me and it's from shudder who
are like four dudes you know I don't
know if I've seen a film produced by
shudder that's a new I think they're
starting to do more and more of that and
cranked up to shouts out to them which I
guess is a new sort of like horror movie
label and I like it's cool to see them
partnering or shudder also because I
think they're doing more original
content now it's a good time for horror
man keep it coming great time for horror
guys check out more from cranked up yeah
all right ladies gentlemen thanks for
watching along you can check this movie
out if this is your first time watching
the trailer I would go the actual
trailer go into the description box yeah
go check it out cuz you got to watch
this trailer and big in a bigger screen
[ __ ] outside the box you got to watch it
in the full format of your iPhone yeah I
know most of you watch from mobile get
all six of those inches alright guys
well you can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification about to
get notified every time one of our
videos is up and make sure to check out
don't leave home September 14th
video in demand and in the theaters boy
in the name of the Father and the Son
and the Holy Ghost on Jesus Christ